I have huge issues with health insurance
I don't actually believe in it I think
we should abolish it completely it's
actually a form of nationalized
healthcare that doesn't work because
it's it's only available to few and not
everybody and it seems like we already
have mechanisms in place like Medicare
and Medicaid to take care of
catastrophic situations so if you can
divert health insurance money into into
a larger pool to handle catastrophic
situations then you don't need health
insurance what that would do to the
overall economy I don't know and I'm
sure there's plenty of economists who
would disagree with getting rid of
health insurance because of the jobs
that it creates but personally I just
feel that a twenty to twenty percent
profit margin on an individual's health
is immoral and unnecessary and then once
catastrophic is guaranteed and paid for
by the by the government essentially we
don't have to worry about it and you
move into a competitive market and you
make your preventive care paid for on an
as-needed basis which sort of changes
the entire model of expectation of how
to take care of yourself so you make
sure you go to the doctor once a year
you exercise more you eat better because
if you if you take care of yourself
it'll cost you less money then the
services become competitive so you can
actually shop around you're not
restricted to an in-network type of
doctor or that sort of situation and I
think you will see a drop in the
expenses of how much health care is and
everyone will be able to afford it and
we'll go to the doctor why we expect
preventive care health to be paid for by
anybody is is sort of a strange
phenomena and it also causes a lopsided
service within within within the economy
and for the pop general population
the model that the freelancers union has
is is actually probably a step in that
direction in a way because they've taken
it on their own providing their own
service of health insurance reducing the
profit margin eliminating it giving the
power of group to negotiate rates down
and everything you still have the
fundamental issue of in network and lack
of choice but it does create a model
that's more affordable for for
freelancers so it's a it's a necessary
stopgap I think to probably the ultimate
goal which is to abolish health
insurance by and large you know if you
go if you look at the differences
between how much health insurance costs
in New York State versus how much health
insurance costs in Iowa say it's a
dramatic difference and that just
shouldn't exist that the inequality of
why health insurance costs more in
certain places and not in the others is
it just shouldn't exist
I look at them as almost unattractive
just because of the nightmares that they
that they sort of project if you look at
the National Health Service in England I
know people think of that as like how
not to provide health health care and
which is which is why the concept of a
competitive health health care market
becomes much more attractive than a
completely nationalized one what you
want to do is create an environment
where people are seeking services for
what they need and not unnecessarily
health insurance actually makes you seek
services unnecessarily because you want
to get more bang for your buck just
because a corporation or a company
provides your health care doesn't mean
that it's not being paid for and it's an
unnecessary weight on on corporations to
have to pay a thousand-dollar dollars a
month per employee to be competitive in
a market for health insurance it's just
it's it's a lot of money that is going
into other people's pockets
unnecessarily
it sounds like it seems like several
wits and the freelancers union is
actually making a making strides and in
and helping the independent worker but I
really can't speak too much upon it
because I'm not that familiar with it
and give you my personal take on
retirement savings which which is just
my own personal confusion as to how the
stock market actually works in our and
our current times as a contemporary
stock market versus like its its
previous inception which was to help
companies expand give them money to to
do there to do their work and everything
it seems like we're moving towards a d
corporatization of of the country
because corporations actually
fundamentally are flawed for some reason
and and are so so in that sense it feels
like why are we pouring more money into
the stock market do we really understand
when we put money into the stock market
how it's being used we're trusting funds
to be managed by very few people in the
country and to invest it wisely and
we're looking at bottom line returns and
everything and the expectation is to to
get a return on that vs vs thinking of
it in terms of i would like to invest in
this company because it's a green
company and i believe in it and i'm not
going to worry about the return I'm
actually putting my money in there
because i want that company to do well
so the the model of retirement savings
is is a broken one in a way because the
expectation is you need a seven to
eleven percent return over the life of
your annually over the life of your
investments over 30 years or whatever so
you can have enough money to retire with
retirement is a strange concept to me as
well as a freelancer because I don't
believe I'll ever retire and so I sort
of have I have very mixed feelings about
putting money into into a retirement
plan right now I do I my own investment
plan is I put a hundred dollars a month
into Intel into a dividend reinvestment
plan because I believe in technology I
love technology I'm an addicted
technophobe or whatever and
and so I give Intel a hundred dollars a
month I give that them I don't expect
anything I hope it does well you know
the dream would be to you know have the
stock grow and double and do all those
those sorts of things but those are pipe
dreams really in the end you can't Bank
on that you can't you can't rely on that
so I have no I have no current plan in
my retirement savings because I don't
have enough money to do that I wish I
did